la profesora Isabel Cruz enseña en una
escuela donde debe aplicar un nuevo plan
de estudios Pero ella no está dispuesta
a hacerlo porque acusa al gobierno de
incluir en historia la narrativa de que
en 2019 hubo un golpe de estado contra
Evo Morales sin considerar otras
versiones de esa crisis política que ha
polarizado al país
pero el gobierno al intentar dar esta
narrativa del golpe de estado lo único
que haces invisibilizar todo lo que ha
sucedido por ejemplo cuando habla de
golpe de estado Yo no me siento
representada tampoco cuando hablan de
fraude yo me siento representada cuando
ha habido un malestar una rebelión
popular que ha salido por sus propias
necesidades los educadores han
denunciado en las calles el supuesto
adoctrinamiento político pero grupos de
padres de familia también se han
manifestado para rechazar la nueva
currícula Porque contiene un enfoque de
género y educación sexual para primaria
No puede ser que niños de 4 a 6 años
empiecen a llevar materias con temas de
sexualidad nosotros creemos firmemente
que los niños tienen que jugar tienen
que aprender no tienen que hablar de
sexualidad esa edad el gobierno asegura
que los libros tendrán pluralidad
política y que el enfoque de género será
respetuoso de la edad de los niños por
lo que considera que las críticas
provienen de sectores radicales que
cuestionan el modelo de país que fija
Constitución porque todo este tema de la
doctrinamiento género como les decía
hace tiempo hace un momento está en la
Constitución
descolonización
despatriarcalización
intraculturalidad interculturalidad
plurilingüismo todos estos temas están
en la Constitución no no podemos
nosotros como Ministerio de Educación
Ese es el horizonte de sociedad que
tenemos los estudiantes son ajenos a las
polémicas pero el gobierno los maestros
y los padres reconocen que la educación
no es neutral así la currícula se ha
convertido en el nuevo campo de la
polarización en Bolivia